This man is worth 5,564,800,000 Berries. How
much is that you ask? Given that one berry
is pretty much the same as one yen, and one
hundred yen are about 1 American dollar, that
would make Gol D. Roger's head worth 55,648,000
million Dollars. In other words, catching
Roger would have bought you this nice little
yacht, about 1500 bitcoins or 55 million pieces
of okay-tasting gum. Something, which sounds
like a Mr. Beast Video.
Unsurprisingly, it is by far the highest bounty
we have seen in the story so far, an with
the notable exceptions of Luffy and his father
dragon, there doesn't seem to be anyone out
there who will ever be able to match it. As
the first pirate king and the only known captain
to ever reach the end of the grand line, it
is to be expected that Roger would have a
high bounty, but being a great adventurer
and notorious pirate alone, doesn't explain
a bounty that in the One Piece world would
basically make you royalty. The reason Gold
Roger was so infamous and dangerous to the
world government lies within his character,
that tells us a lot about where Luffy is heading
in the story as well. It's a story about freedom.
About power. About camaraderie. About Politics,
History and the most infamous treasure in
the world, the One Piece itself. This is the
story of Gol D. Roger.
Roger's character was inspired by two real
pirates, Olivier Levasseur and Henry Every.
Leavesseur became known for tossing a cryptogram
from his execution platform into the crowd,
telling them, that the hidden message on it
would lead them to his gigantic treasure,
that to this day hasn't been found. This of
course directly parallels Roger's legendary
speech at his execution. - But it also seems
like a likely inspiration for the poneglyphs,
stones written in a forgotten language, that
lead to the last island of the grand line,
laugh tale, where the one piece is hidden.
Every on the other hand, became famous for
being the richest pirate in the world, earning
him the epithet 'king of the pirates'. Despite
having the highest bounty in history of around
$700,000 USD in today's currency, placed on
his head, he vanished with the legendary treasure
he accumulated over his life in the Caribbean,
which at that time used to be known as the
new world. He was the inspiration for a new
generation of notorious pirates, including
Blackbeard,Bartholomew Roberts,Calico
Jack,Samuel BellamyandEdward Low, among
others, who were children at the time. And
I know what you're thinking now: Ohara - This
dude's nose looks just like a Dong. Well,
why do you think he became one of the most
violent pirates of all time. Exactly, because
of comments like that. Stop it!
## Roger's role within the story is extremely
interesting in many ways. He quite literally
is a legendary pirate, in the sense that his
tale is a story whiting the story. By doing
so, Oda advances his own world building, introduces
the inspiration for Luffy and many other characters,
while at the same time drawing a number of
parallels between the nested story and the
main story line. Roger's character, right
form the start explains why so many people
in this world are pirates, next to the injustice
of the world government of course. Interestingly
enough, the more we learn about him and the
people around him, unlike in many other stories,
where the real deal can't live up to the legend,
in Roger's case, he becomes even more impressive
a person the more we learn about him. One
of the strongest and most free-spirited characters
in the story, not bound by anything or anyone.
And of course the more we learn about him,
the more we see the parallels between him
and Luffy.
First of all I think it's really interesting
to see that the apparently unattainable goal
that Luffy has at the beginning of the story,
in other words, becoming pirate king, has
already been achieved by this other legendary
character. In fact, all the things that come
with the title, that usually should be unique
to the main character of the story, have all
been done before. Finding Laugh Tale at the
end of the grand line, learning the true history
of the world and discovering the biggest treasure
out there - literally from the get-go we are
being told that all of these things have already
been achieved by some other dude 20 years
ago. Kind of unexciting for Luffy to then
just repeat what Roger already did. However,
when you really think about it, what it pretty
much guarantees for us, is that Luffy will
in some shape or form overcome Roger and his
legacy. He will do what even the first pirate
king could not do, which most likely is change
the unjust world order.
We actually know for a fact, that while both
Luffy and Roger share the same dream, this
dream is not actually becoming pirate king,
that title didn't even exist before Roger
in the first place. Rather, whatever this
dream is, it will have something to do with
the main theme of the story: Freedom. And
while Roger managed to live a life of freedom
with his crew, Luffy will be the one to bring
it to everyone, in whatever shape or form
that will be. That's why the parallels between
them are so important. The same hat inherited
from Roger, the same will of D both carry
in their name, the voices of all things, their
inclusive and quirky crews and even parts
of their personality seem to match, as Luffy
and Roger share a number of lines throughout
the story. Hell, when you look at adult Luffy,
he even looks like Roger. At the same time
of course, they aren't the same person. As
we have seen throughout the Oden flashback
in Wano, while similar, Luffy and Roger are
still different people and Luffy certainly
is the turned-version of some of the traits
that made Roger so special in the first place.
As we now know, Roger was waiting for someone
like Luffto appear. - Most likely after
abandoning his crew in anticipation of his
death, he instructed his remaining crew to
look for the one who could become the new
pirate king and finish what he couldn't. Crocus
and Rayleigh are positioned suspiciously strategically
at the entrances of the grand line and the
new world respectively, keeping an eye out
for whoever enters. And both go them make
explicit comparisons between Roger and Luffy.
- And then of course there is Shanks, who
surely didn't bet his arm on a little boy
on a whim. He is certain that Luffy will ring
in a new age. So, it's extremely likely Roger
entrusted him with his hat, to find his successor
and entrust that hat to him in return. -
And this is already the first reason that
Roger earned himself this ridiculous bounty
of 5,5 Billion Berry. Being the only known
person in the story so far to rave laugh tale
and learn the real history, he possesses knowledge
that the world government has actively tried
to eradicate for centuries. And not in the
nice, 'hey let's all not talk about it anymore'
sort of way, but more as in, if you so much
as try to learn about the past, we will come
with our magma psychopath and burn your whole
darn island to the ground - sort of way. As
Rayleigh tells us, Roger and his crew learned
about the true history, which without any
other factors involved would already save
him a top position on the bounty board. Just
look at what happened to Robin when she was
not even a teenager.
But on top of that, Roger had both the intend
to act upon that knowledge AND the power to
actually do so. I mean the guy clashed with
anyone who is known to be strong in the story:
Garp, WHitebeard, Kaido, Shiki, Big Mom, Rocks
himself. What a god damn monster. --
There are usually two ways to raise your bounty
in the one piece world: Be extremely strong,
be extremely influential or actively try to
work against the established world order.
Well, as you know, Roger did all 3 of these
things. And so it's no real surprise, that
the most legendary character in One piece
ended up with the most legendary bounty. - [fame,
wealth,..]
I this wasn't enough legendary old guy for
you yet, I strongly recommend watching this
video on Rayleigh or this one on Garp next.
Thanks for watching. Peace.